We'd like to play a quick round of...
Drewth or Dare.
(crowd cheers and claps)
(Ross laughs)
And today we have Kat Lejer.
Hi, Kat.
Hello. Hi.
Oh, I wanted to, I just told you,
I said I think that this is one of my favorite
audience member outfits ever.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
So, what's it gonna be, a Drewth or a dare?
Drewth.
Okay.
So Drew, have you ever bribed
or flirted your way out of a ticket?
Yes.
You have?
Oh, 100%.
Give me a story.
Well, I don't know if I would flirt per se,
but I've definitely come up with a host of excuses
and maybe one or two times it worked and a bunch, it didn't.
I got my license taken away when I was like 17
'cause I had like repeat offenders
and then I've kind of reigned it in after that, like check.
I thought you'd be so good at it.
You'd just like play with your hair and be like,
"Oh, I'm sorry, was that a red light, I didn't know."
(crowd laughs)
Right, see if you do this.
Yeah, yeah.
No it, it's, yeah.
Sometimes it's worked, sometimes it hasn't.
Yeah.
We've all been there, right?
Yeah, I have definitely.
And what did you do, Kat?
I bribed.
And? Wait, what'd you say, what'd you bribe?
So, just like a few years ago,
I got pulled over by a cop
and when he was walking over I noticed
that he was the cop that is dating my best friend.
So when he came in, I was like,
if you give me this ticket I am calling her
and there's no more dates after that.
(Ross gasps) (all laugh)
He let me out on a warning, so that was good.
Wow, that went well.
Mm-hmm.
Thank you Kat, so much.
Thank you, it was great meeting you guys.
It was so great meeting you.
(upbeat theme music)